um so hi everyone um so I'm goingon to
be talking a little bit about some work
on probalistic
databases uh and approximations and uh
it's joint work together with Anon and K
who are both here today so you can also
ask them if you're interested this um so
when I first uh propose this talk um is
talk about intentional querer evaluation
and I thought I would be the only one
talking about intentional quer valuation
at the workshop it turns out yesterday
um I saw over the weekend that Dan and
Mel also had uh talks on this topic and
so this is actually quite closely
related to what I'm going to be talking
about today um the difference is is that
very roughly is that um I'm going to be
talking about compiling to less
tractable circuits so instead of
compiling to things like obdds or ddn
NFS I'm going to be talk about compiling
to um something called non-deterministic
obdds and structured DF circuits
um and these are circuits that uh admit
proximate counting rather than exact
counting and I'm going to be measuring
everything in terms of combined
complexity rather than data complexity
uh like I talked about
yesterday also very relevant is uh
marcelo's talk tomorrow um so all the
approximation results uh that I'll be
talking about here um are actually using
this FP for counting strings except to
buy an
Aon and uh so I mean he'll give you the
details of this
tomorrow
okay so I'm going to start by um just
going over some background and reminding
you about this probalistic databases
problem talk a little bit about the uh
complexity um then I'm going to focus on
the results so I'm going to First Look
at um developing approximation schemes
when we don't restrict the database
instance in any way and then uh in the
case where we restrict the instance and
then it'll be briefly talking about some
lower bounds and inapproximability
results and I'll
conclude
so uh this is a standard relational
model I think everyone's seen this
before we're going to be looking at what
are called Boolean conjunctive queries
so you can ask a question like uh you
know is there some X and Y that
satisfies both of these items these are
called BL conjuncted queries if you know
first to of logic these are just
existentially Quantified positive
conjunctive sentences that's what we're
going to be focusing on here um I want
to emphasize these are Boolean queries
so we're really interested in yes or no
answers we're not leaving any variables
free here um so everything is is f okay
so that's a standard relational model we
can ask Boolean conductor queries on a
on a database um but about maybe 20
years ago um delv and suo noticed that
this is sort of U maybe a little bit
underere equipped to deal with
uncertainty if you imagine the processes
that populate these databases are often
populated in a in a automated fashion
and they can be noisy so you need some
uh model that can deal with this these
probabilities okay so the solution is
very simple um you add uh probability
labels to each of your tupal in your
database and the semantics are going to
be as follows you're sort of going to
flip a coin with this uh the given
probability for every row and with that
probability uh if it comes up Tails
you're going to delete it and if it
comes up heads you're going to keep it
in your database and you're interested
now in asking the question of what is
the probability um that my original
query which is Boolean um is going to
valate to true on this database that you
sample so you're basically just deleting
rows from your original instance and
you're interested in knowing the final
probability so just to make this clear
with an example suppose for example we
were to uh Delete the second row here
and the second row in here that happens
with these probabilities everything is
independent so we can multiply all these
probabilities together to compute the
probability of this sub instance and it
turns out this particular subes still
satisfies the query that we had a couple
slides ago so we can just
SU
okay so the problem of Interest here
that we're looking at is the
problemistic query evaluation problem
you're given a Boolean query and one of
these Tuple independent probabilistic
databases and you're interested in
finding out the query probability so
it's a sum of all probabilities of all
the sub instances that satisfy your
query for the purpose of this talk I'm
going to be focusing on a special case
of this although everything extends to
the weighted case um which is the
uniform reliability problem so that's
where you give each tupal or each factor
in your database probably of a half and
if you think about then really what
you're doing it's the same thing as
counting the number of sub businesses
that satisfy your query up to some
Conant
Factor um so what's known about this
problem um so I think this is talked
about a little B about yesterday about
just review um this is um sharpy hard in
data complexity for most conjunctive
queries so that means when I fix a query
and I look at my database as input um
depending on the query I fix this may be
sharpy hard or maybe polinomial time for
most queries
uh this is uh sharpy hard and so the
simplest example of such a query is if
you take this rst query then you can
reduce from this uh cly partitioned 2
dnf counting problem and show that this
a sharpy it turns out for a whole bunch
of queries um called the unsafe queries
you can always find such a
reduction um and then for some queries
the so-called safe queries you have
polinomial time data complexing okay so
there's a polinomial Time Sharpie hard
dichotomy result approved uh and then
with a little bit more work uh you can
extend this to uqs and that was
done okay um what's interesting here is
that the combined complexity of this is
mostly still open with I think the
exception of one paper that looks at a
um a special case of probabilistic
graphs which I'll talk about a bit later
um but the combined complexity is really
you it cannot be easier than the data
complexity right I mean if your input
query class has an unsafe query then the
combined complexity is going to be sharp
so already for data complexity that's a
very challenging problem and in Combined
complexity it's basically
even okay and then you have um as well
as this you have these results on
intentional uh querer evaluation so um
most of these safe uqs have a a
tractable representation of their
Provence as computable in Pol normal
time in the database size okay so this
is what uh Dan and Mikel both talked
about yesterday of course there's this
uh you know still open problem of
whether all of these uh UC Qs that um
are safe have such a tractable
representation um but for most of them
we can get some tractable representation
so um basically for example if you look
at this example here um you have here a
very simple query and this database so
we can compile this to an ordered binary
decision diagram and you can sort of
imagine this as saying well okay if I
want my query to be true on any sub
instance well I either need to have the
TS one two and two three or I need to
have the tups 24 and 44 and then I don't
care about the other tups so that's
effectively what this binary decision
diagram is encoding and so if you do
your model counting process on this
binary decision diagram which can be
done in Pol normal time then you get
your uniform reliability and if you do
weit in modal counting you can do the
probabilistic okay so that's sort of the
state-ofthe-art I guess in terms of uh
exact um but then this sort of a natural
question is like you know now we're in
deterministic querer evaluation you know
we're Computing yes or no now in
probabilistic databases we're Computing
a number so it's a natural question to
ask can we approximate this number you
so can we approximate the probability of
a query
okay um and the other thing is that um
as I mentioned most of these results are
written in terms of data complexity so
it'd be nice if we could sort of find
um places where query that where there's
also not such an exponential dependence
on the query okay so the question is can
we get larger class attractable queries
with polinomial dependence on both the
query and the database size by allowing
for randomized approximations so to
formalize this a little bit uh is what
query classes q and instant classes D
can we get an algorithm such that for
any Epsilon and Delta you give me and
any queries and databases from these
classes I can compute the probability of
this query on this database within a 1
plusus Epsilon error factor with one
minus Delta probability and a runtime
that's polinomial that's both in the
query and the database
okay um and I'm going to call an
algorithm that satisfies these
conditions a combined FP s okay so
combined because it's both polinomial
dependence in in Q and in
D okay and the interesting thing here is
that we're going to be to to find these
combined fpes I'm going to be taking a
fully intentional approach so I'm going
to be compiling um these uh queries and
instances together to circuits that are
combined Pol normal size and I'm going
to be focusing as my target um circuits
that I'm known to admit an FP Ras by the
recent results of um Marcelo that he's
going to be talking about tomorrow okay
so currently these these circuit classes
are non-deterministic obdds which I'll
talk about in a minute and structured
dnf
circuits okay before we go there I just
want to motivate a little bit better
like why we're looking at both query and
instance size so one question you could
ask is you know maybe I don't care so
much about the dependence on the query
and I'm happy just with the polinomial
dependence on the
database if you do that and you relax
this runtime restriction to only have a
polinomial dependence on the database it
turns out you can actually get an fpr
ask for all uh uqs in any instance by
Computing the provence of the query in
uh in dnf okay and dnf is known to admit
NFP Ras by very old results um but the
problem with this is is that the size of
this dnf has um a exponential dependency
that looks like this so basically you've
got the query in the exponent here and
your database is usually in practice
quite large so if you had for example a
database with a few hundred tupal and
only five atom query you're can end up
with a dnf over one trillion Clauses and
so this is really infusible to
materialize so even if you have a great
dnf counter you're not even be able
going to be able to write out the
dnf so that's why we're really looking
for um a dependence of polinomial on
both the query
and okay so a couple observations first
very obvious observation I guess is that
if your query class your database class
emits tractable exact prob to query
valuation then of course you have
combined FS the other one that's maybe
slightly less obvious but uh still worth
mentioning here is that um if your query
and database class admit a uh combined
FPS in the sense that we talked about a
moment ago then they can cannot have NP
hard combined complexity for
deterministic quer evaluation so why is
that okay suppose um you know what you
can do is you can say let's say q and d
have NP hard combined complexity okay
then we could run our combined FP Ros on
Tuple independent database where all the
probabilities are one then you sort of
are saying well MP is in BPP and so RP
equals MP okay so basically you're just
reducing this uh probabilistic database
problem it's I mean you can sort of see
it as a or sorry the deterministic quer
evaluation problem you can see it as a
special case of the probabilistic query
evaluation problem in some
sense okay um so the first uh setting I
want to talk about is where I make no
assumptions on the database instance
okay and then um the result we can get
is as follows so any query you give me
which is self- joint free and has
bounded hypert tree width I can get a
combined FP for this okay and the reason
for this is well we need the bounded
hypert tree width because this is a
sufficient condition to guarantee exact
uh sorry a deterministic career
evaluation okay and so really the only
extra restriction I have here is the
self- drain freeness
okay so I'll sort of sketch how you get
this result and the idea is that like I
said we're going to be taking an
intentional approach so we're going to
be constructing a non- ristic obdd that
represents the pro into the query okay
so we're really going to be harnessing
the power of the ability to add
disjunctions to my
obdds and so um what is a non teristic
obdd well it's just an obdd but I can
put in or nodes okay and the or nodes
basically just mean what you think they
mean it means that I can basically make
a non-deterministic choice of whether I
go to the left or to the right okay so
how does the construction work so if you
take a look here at my query because
this is self join free I can sort of
split it into three layers one for each
uh one for each atom and I'm first going
to look at the first itom
okay and uh essentially I'm going to
look and look at the possible matches of
this query and I can sort of say okay
well you know to for this query to
evaluate to True either I can go one two
2 3 33 something like that or I could go
22 23 33 and so on but effectively the
only things that are going to lead me to
an answer positive uh answer to this
this query are going to be either by
taking the first row or the third row
okay so I can make this
non-deterministic choice of where I go
here okay so I can go either I have R12
or I have R22 okay now every single
possible answer to this query if you
take a look at this instance also has to
pass through two three here so we have
the the uh the one nodes going through
here through two three and then so on um
and then again we can use disjunction
here once I get to 23 I can make almic
choice so whether I'm going to have 33
or 34 as my
witnessing okay so we're just basically
using disjunction in the n obdd and it
turns out we can then now get something
that's a pol normal size both in the
query and the database okay now by uh by
the fact that nistic obdds uh you can
approximate the number of models you now
have your FP Ras
for
so um the second um case that I'm going
to look at here is ask okay now that was
works for any database instance you give
me now what if I want to put some
restrictions on the database instance
class then can I maybe get a more
expressive classic queries that don't
have the self joint fore restriction
right so I'm going to be looking at a
really special case of uh pris database
and that's probalistic graphs okay so
that's where I I'm going to restrict my
query and my instance to a b binary
signature okay so now I've instead of
using Q for query I'm going to say G and
instance I'm going to instead of saying
D I'm going to say h and I you can sort
of look at these as graphs and H um is
going to be annotated with probability
values on all the edes
okay and I'm going to compute the
probability essentially that a subgraph
of h adits a home morphism from G and if
you think about what this is asking it's
the same thing as
evaluating uh a query on a binary on a
database over a binary signature
okay and uh you can distinguish in this
uh case between two settings so you have
the labeled setting which is really
where we are in probity databases where
I place no restrictions on um the number
of relations I have my signature you can
also look um because this is graphs it's
sort of interesting also to look at the
unlabeled setting so in this setting I
have a fixed signature and I have only
one relationing appearing in it and I'm
going to look at a quite a large variety
of different graph classes here okay so
um I'm going to look at um these classes
here so I'll briefly sketch out what
these classes are so the first class is
are what are called one-way path classes
okay so these are um just path queries
with all the edges going in one
direction we also have two-way path
queries with uh sort of the same thing
but we now allow edges to go in a
different direction you also look at
downwards tree queries so these are
basically a directed tree where all of
my edges are pointing away from the root
of the tree uh poly trees which are the
same thing as this except here I don't
place any restriction on which way the
edges Point um so I could have some of
the edges pointing towards the root and
some away from the root uh directed a
cyclic graphs so that's what you think
it is and then uh connected directed
graphs so just arbitrary uh directed
graphs
B and depending um on the restrictions I
place
on my uh query graph and my instance
graph I can get a whole bunch of
different approximability and
inapproximability
results okay so again this is all in
Combined complexity I've split it up
here into two tables uh one is the
labeled case so this is the standard
problemistic database setting where I
place no restrictions on uh the number
of relations I use and one is the
unlabeled setting where I have only one
relation and in this table I've sort of
got three colors here I don't know how
well the gray shows up here but
effectively what this means that if I
for example have a query here a oneway
path query on a one-way path instance if
this is white here then that means that
this is in polinomial time and combined
complexity so these results actually
already known but what's new here is
that we now also have approximability
results so the light gray here means
that for example if I have a oneway path
query and a poly tree or a dag instance
uh then although this is Sharpie hard
there is now an FP uh there's an FP R
for this okay and I'll show how we get
this FP R in a minute for the ones that
are in Black here these are ones that
are Sharpie hard but we also know we can
provably show that there's uh no FP Ross
uh for these settings um subject to
standard complexity theoretic
assumptions okay and again it's the same
thing for the unlabeled case although
you have a little bit more that's
tractable in the unlabeled case because
you have this restri and you only have
one relation
so I'm just going to um sort of
highlight one particular uh track one
particular FP result because turns out
that it's really effectively the only FP
result we have here
um and um this is essentially looking at
one-way path queries on labeled directed
aycl graphs and so the result here says
that any one-way path query on any label
directed is CYCC graph
I can get a combined FPS for this
problem and it's the same idea as what
we had a few slides ago we're going to
be constructing a nistic obdd that
represents the provence and then we'll
appeal to this sharp NFA result that I
mentioned earlier and the ordering um uh
that's we're going to get in this uh ndd
is going to be given by a topological
ordering of the edges of the dag and
you'll see how this comes in just a
second so here's for an example here's a
query I have a query of like three
um you'll notice this is not self joint
free anymore so now I allow uh for
example our device here I've written
this just in the graph notation here so
this is exact same thing as saying rxy r
y z szw for example and then now I've
also written my instance in this sort of
graph uh notation just to make it a
little bit easier to read and the idea
what we're going to do is we're going to
basically take the disjunction of the
non teristic obdd corresponding to all
the possible starting points of a match
of the query so for example I could have
a path of length three that starts at
one here that goes for example r r and
then s or I could for example go r r and
s or I could start at four here and then
go r r s I could start at four here go R
RS I'm all the possible starting points
I'm going to take their disjunction and
for each possible starting point I'm
going to um uh build an
nodd so let's just see the example for
one possible starting point which is at
0.1 so if you think about it here it's
really just the same idea I mean we can
we know here we're forced to take our
one two to start and then we have a
choice right so we can either go towards
five or we can go towards three so we
have this disjunction here okay and then
um once I for example pick to take uh
this uh this route in this in this uh in
the split here then I'm sort of forced
to go to 56 so that's what you see here
for example R12 two five and then 56 and
then I've got a match so we're really
taking advantage of the determin of the
non-determinism here and the ability to
add this Junction to deal with these
cases in the directed cyc graph instance
where I have an outdegree of more than
one so that's the case for the path
starting at node one really the only
other possible place I can start um in
this graph just still get a match will
be node four and it's really exactly the
same thing except you know here we're
replacing the uh first edge with 42
instead of one two and then everything
else in the ndd Remains the
Same okay and then the nice thing about
this is that from this uh we can also
get an extra result from this um so you
can also get a result on a problem from
operations research called two terminal
Network reliability or St reliability so
this is a problem where you're given a
directed graph um with uh independent
Edge probability labels
and you basically want to compute the
probability that if you randomly sample
a sub subgraph according to this
distribution that you can get a path
between the two terminals you specified
okay and the cool thing is that using
the construction that I I just showed
and or something very similar is that
you get an FP R for this St reliability
problem at dgs and this is a problem
that was open for some time and uh yeah
so and independently I think weing who's
here also found uh an FP for this
problem
very um and so the idea is that here
we're going to take a disjunction over
all of the connecting Paths of different
lengths so in this case you can see for
example if I specify one and six as my
two terminal nodes any possible path uh
from one to six is going to have length
three so I can only just focus on the
case where I have a path of length three
and we can construct an ndd using the
same idea um and we're sort of basically
enforcing that I start at one and I end
at six and again we're just using this
disjunction idea whenever I need to make
this nistic choice of where
I okay and then I also want to talk a
little bit about lower bounds so
inapproximability results um as well so
one natural question that you could have
when you see this uh is that you know
could it be tra could it be the case
that everything that's tractable in a
combined complexity for deterministic
quer evaluation also admits a combined f
p for probabilistic query evaluation
okay so for example bounded hypert tree
width we know that's a sufficient
condition to guarantee tractable uh
exact query or deterministic query
evaluation could it be the case that all
everything with bounded hypertree width
um I can also get a combined FP for
probabilistic the probabilistic qu
valuation problem the answer in fact is
no and in fact already in a very
restricted case we can show The
Following we can show that again subject
to some complexity theoretic assumptions
even on a fixed signature with only a
single binary relation so like an
unlabeled graph for example there's no
FP to approximate the probability of a
tree with one conjuncted query on a tree
with one instance okay so um it turns
out that basically that getting these
combined FP rasses is in fact quite
difficult and uh if you're interested in
how this is proved very roughly how you
the sketch for this is um you reduce
from monotone to CNF of boundary degree
and uh to this probabilistic qu
valuation
um another question is about circuit
sizes okay so um I mean we're
constructing these circuits and uh to
get all of these results so I mean
although it's possible that uh I mean we
know there's no fpr existing but could
it be that there are still small
circuits right it this might take
exponential time to compute these
circuits or these uh
ndds um so could we could it be the case
that you have these compact
representations of Provence always
existing despite sometimes being hard to
compute and the answer again here is no
so it turns out you can show that for um
that there's an infinite family of path
queries and an infinite family of
instances um such that any dnf circuit
capturing the Providence of these
queries on these databases must have
exponential size and in particular this
already holds for dnf circuits so this
also implies exponential lower bounds
for more tractable forms so things like
dnns structured dnfs and so
on um and also this is sort of
interesting uh because these are path
queries right so we know that path
queries are uh linear time combined
complexity to evaluate exactly but to
get even just a mildly tractable
representation of their Provence um we
need something that's exponentially
sized again uh very roughly if you're
interested in the details of how this is
proved um you can find families of
monotone 2 cnfs that have bounded
variable occurrence but their smallest
dnf is exponentially sized and then by
using the reduction uh in our previous
results um you just look at the query
instance families you get and that gives
you okay so I think I'm just about out
of time so I'll just wrap up um
so um there's lots of interesting
directions here that I see for future
work um so the most obvious one is
generalizing these results so um a lot
of these results that I showed were for
probalistic graphs so it be interesting
to generalize this to like higher a
instances and the main positive result
we had on these graphs were on dags so
there is Notions of like for example
bounded dag width I don't know if that
generalizes to that or not maybe someone
who knows more about that can tell me
and um also obviously to more expressed
queries so everything we looked at were
just conjunctive queries you can also
ask about things like negation recursion
and so
on um another natural question is you
know so we compil to to no obdds which
are really just a special case of
structured
dnf and it's also natural to ask what
other formalisms admit tractable
approximate counting okay so for example
could we get a result for unstructured
dnf circuits um so maybe Marcelo will
have some ideas on that when he he talks
tomorrow but and uh if so what are the
implications for fistic query evaluation
so can we find queries that have small
unstructured dnf circuits even though
they might have large structured dnf
circuits um also because I mean uh I
know a lot of people at the workshop are
from AI background I mean I think this
result is quite interesting because uh
it gives us a very uh easy and lazy way
to get an FP R without having to get our
hands dirty and so could you apply this
FP here to other problems in AI so for
example in Gra iCal models or from model
counting on General circuits you know
getting parameterized counting results
there been a little bit of work on that
uh on parameter called CV withth which
gives you a parameter on cnfs to compile
to structured uh
dnf and then the last thing is making
all of this practical so I mean now uh
these are some interesting applications
of this nistic obdd results um so I
think these results sort of motivate the
development of like a a really a
practical approximate counter for
structure DF
circuit so um I think with that I'm just
about out of time so I'll conclude
[Applause]
thanks have
questions so supposed
to
we do have fre variables so have you
thought about a problem of uh sampling
from the space of
outputs it's also related to marcelo's
talk couple weeks about ago about the
sampling from determin
queries um I guess the short answer is
no I I haven't thought about that um so
I I guess here we're really assuming
everything is is a boo query because
that's usually in probalistic database
these are sort of the semantics that
people look at maybe this been work that
generalizes this to allow for free
variables or maybe there's an natural
generalization but off the top of my
head I I don't know
good yeah so um one norog um type of
open problems is to characterize the
data complexity for approximation but
for universally Quantified uh queries
yes that are found in N representations
like Mark of logic Networks um does your
work give us any insight on into that
problem which as far as I know is
completely open yes I've thought about
this problem as well as far as I know
it's open I don't see directly how to
apply this to NE I mean effectively I
guess it would be like applying this to
queries with negation is what the
equivalent think would be guess
disjunction right if you put a negation
negation yeah
um it's I mean it's an interesting
question we didn't look at it uh yet um
but that's sort of next logical Next
Step so I think you know looking at
negation and then
you it's an interesting question but we
haven't thought about that
yet other
questions so I actually have a question
like um are these um FP R actually
tractable from a practical point of view
like can you actually I think currently
my understanding is no but I know I've
talked to at least three or four people
here who are all independently saying
they're working on this so right I'm
pretty confident that hopefully in a
couple years we'll have something that
okay great it's recorded you know
right right do we have more
questions push but ah it's already
pushed uh this may be an weird questions
or not so uh I'm working on baso network
not on probabilistic data databases so
the corresponding questions when instead
of the data being a database being based
in network did you think about the class
of questions answering queries the
tability of those Boolean queries over a
basian network I have not thought about
that but I mean when I wrote the uh
slide here I did think about this
question because I think I mean
effectively I guess the main message
here is that you now have a very easy
way to reduce to this problem to this
you know by by building a circuit you
now can do
approximation and so this is one
application of that but for example you
could ask the same question is there
some parameter maybe something uh less
restriced than treewidth for example
because treewidth gives you exact
tractability Invasion networks is there
some less uh restrictive parameter for
beijan networks such that you can
compile to a circuit for example like
one of these circuits and then use the
FP there so that that's sort of what I
was thinking along lines
here Network because this is conjunctive
C with weights so this is the same
problem I'm not sure because hyper three
with yes hyper three with I'm not sure
for publicistic queries yeah okay
yeah just a comment so there is work
about answering constraint based Network
constraint questions which is Laban
questions on Bas in network without I
mean translating to circuits you can
also do it that way but you right that
the tractability is based on the three
with
yeah other
questions
no okay so let's thank the speaker
again we take